(suspenseful music)
(protesters chant)
- Say their names!
Say their names!
(suspenseful music)
- George Floyd
- [News Anchor] George Floyd
repeatedly told the officers
that he could not breathe,
after an officer knelt on his neck.
- The family of George Floyd
held the memorial in his memory.
- My brother's gone, but the
Floyd name still lives on.
(crowd cheers and claps)
- [Man In Crowd] Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
- [Narrator] George Floyd.
You are gone but not forgotten.
Because of you, we've come together.
- This is for George Floyd.
- It's alright to be angry.
And we are going to take our anger,
and our indignation, and
turn it in to energy.
- [Protesters] What's his name?!
George Floyd!
What's his name?!
What do we want?!
Justice!
- [Narrator] To march.
- [Protesters] Black lives matter!
Black lives matter!
- [Narrator] To dance.
(Street band plays upbeat music)
- [Narrator] To kneel.
To be quiet.
We're saying your name.
- [Protesters] George Floyd!
- Say his name!
- George Floyd!
- [Narrator] We're saying their names.
- Breonna taylor!
- Say her name!
- Breonna Taylor!
(car beeps horn)
- [Narrator] We're being loud.
- Hands up! Don't shoot!
Hands up! Don't shoot!
- Black lives matter!
Black lives matter!
- We're being brave.
- [Man] No!
- [Protesters] Who's streets?!
Our streets!
- [Narrator] We're laughing.
- We're crying.
- [Protesters] I can't breathe.
I can't breathe.
- [Narrator] We're getting engaged.
- She said yes!
(crowd cheers)
- [Narrator] We're getting married.
- We're changing the world.
- [Crowd] Black lives matter!
Black Lives Matter!
(protesters chant in French)
- Justice!
- What do we want?!
- When do we want it?
- Now!
- What do we want?!
- Justice!
- [Man] We gotta be soldiers man.
Let's stop hurtin' each other
and let's get it right, man.
Today is the day, we gonna stand up
for our community, man.
And if we can do this, we can do more.
We just gotta continue on
pushing and don't give up.
- What do we want?
- Justice.
- When do we want it?
- Now.
- What do we want?!
- Justice!
- And when do we want it?
- Now.
- No justice!
- No Peace!
- [Stephen Jackson] He did what?
- [Gianna Floyd] Daddy changed the world.
- [Stephen Jackson]
Daddy changed the world.
(soft piano music)